IN THE NBA RIC BUCHER FOX
SPORTS NBA ANALYST. WELCOME
THANKS FOR HAVING ME FELLAS
LOVE THE THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT BUILDING OUR KIDS INTO
STARS THAT WE CAN JUST SIT
BACK AND RIDE THERE.
THAT'S THE DREAM. ALL RIGHT.
YEAH, MY SON. MY SON IS GOING
TO BE EITHER SIX EIGHT OR SIX
NINE. SO I'M GOING TO
PROBABLY NEED SOME GUIDANCE
FROM YOU ON WHERE I NEED TO
GO IN TERMS OF COACHING AND
ESPECIALLY WHERE HE NEEDS TO
PROBABLY GO TO HIGH SCHOOL.
THAT'S THAT'S PROBABLY A BIG
BIG ONE OF THESE WILL WILL
TAKE CARE OF THAT. ALTHOUGH
HIGH SCHOOL IS VERY OVERHYPED
NOW. IT'S THE AAU PROGRAM
CAN GO TO OKAY IS GOING TO
BE THE DECIDING FACTOR, BUT
CERTAINLY WE CAN WE CAN GET
INTO THAT MY I'M HERE FOR YOU.
WELL HEADS UP HEADS UP FOR
THE NAME MACGYVER LEAF SIX
FOOT EIGHT 200 AND YOU KNOW
35 POUNDS AT YOU KNOW KNOW
THAT I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
REALLY STICKS IN THE MEMORY
AND THAT'S PRETTY ORDINARY
JOHN SMITH JOE.
JOE JONES AND MACGYVER LEAK
NOT LIKE THE OTHERS MITCHIE,
UM TRADE DEADLINE COMING
UP THURSDAY A COUPLE BIG
NAMES. YOU KNOW, HOW
INTERESTING WOULD IT BE OF
LONZO BALL IS AGAIN SOMEWHERE
ELSE. IT JUST SEEMS LIKE HE'S
BEEN PASSED AROUND WE HEARD
MAGIC JOHNSON TALKED ABOUT
HIM HAVING ONE OF THE HIGHEST
POINT GUARD IQS. HE CAN THINK
OF WHAT HAPPENS THERE.
I REALLY OWE YOU SO DON'T
ASK ME TO DIVE INTO MAGICS
COMMENTS ABOUT LONZO PAUL
WITH THAT.
WILL THAT COULD HIJACK THE
SHOW SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON
THAT BUT WHAT I FIND
INTERESTING IS THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF REALLY QUALITY
POINT GUARDS OUT THERE LONZO
BALL BEING ONE KYLE LOWRY
BEING ANOTHER SUPPOSEDLY
MALCOLM BROGDON WITH THE
INDIANA PACERS THERE. THERE
ARE SOME GAME CHANGING POINT
GUARDS THAT ARE ON THE MARKET
AND THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
TEAMS NOTABLY THE LOS ANGELES
USE ONE I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
LONZO. GO BACK TO LA
GO TO THE CLIPPERS CM PAIRED
UP WITH PAUL GEORGE AND KAWHI
LEONARD FROM A DEFENSIVE
STANDPOINT. THAT WOULD JUST
BE A NIGHTMARE FOR OPPOSING
TEAMS AND THEY COULD REALLY
USE A PASS FIRST
POINT GUARD AND AND
CERTAINLY LONZO IS THAT HE'S
ALSO DONE A REMARKABLE JOB OF
IMPROVING HIS HIS
THREE-POINT SHOOTING WHICH IS
FOUR TIMES WHEN YOU WANT TO
PUT THE BALL IN PAUL GEORGE
OR KAWHI LEONARD HAND, SO
I WOULD I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
HIM PLAY ON A MEANINGFUL TEAM
BECAUSE I THINK HE JUST GOT
UNFAIRLY HAMMERED THROUGH NO
FAULT OF HIS OWN BECAUSE IT
DIDN'T WORK OUT WITH THE
LAKERS. HE DIDN'T HE DIDN'T
PROPOSE THAT HE WAS ONE OF
THE BEST POINT GUARDS ARE WAS
GOING TO BECOME A LAKERS
LEGEND OR ANY OF THAT STUFF
HIS DAD DID AND MAGIC IT AND
MAGIC APPEARS TO BE
CONTINUING TO JUST PUT THE
SO HIGH THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO LOOK AT LONZO AND SUGGESTS
THAT HE IS UNDERPERFORMING
AND I LOOK I
APPRECIATE ANY GUY WHO COMES
IN THE LEAGUE BRIAN, YOU KNOW,
THIS THAT THAT YOU GET TO
THE PROS, BUT NOW IT'S A
MATTER OF IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHERE YOU WERE DRAFTED. YOU
GOT TO PROVE YOU CAN PLAY AND
AND IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT WHERE
YOU GET DRAFTED, YOU KNOW,
SOMEBODY DECIDED YOU WERE
WORTH THIS SO IT'S ON THEM AS
MUCH AS YOU TO DEVELOP YOU
TO BE THAT
AT AND YOU KNOW, THE LAKERS
PULLED THE RIPCORD ON THAT
AND A LOT OF THOSE GONE ABOUT
JUST MAKING HIMSELF IN THE
BEST PLAYER. HE CAN BE HE IS
CLEARLY MADE STRIDES. HE'S
CLEARLY WORKED ON HIS
WEAKNESSES. AND SO I FOR THE
KIDS SAKE I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
HIM GO SOMEPLACE WHERE HE'S
MEANINGFUL. BUT YOU KNOW AS
FAR AS GUYS WHO WOULD CHANGE
THE DYNAMIC KYLE LOWRY
POTENTIALLY GOING TO THE
MIAMI HEAT AND WHEREVER
MALCOLM BROGDON WOULD GO. I'M
REALLY SURPRISED BY THE
PACERS.
WANTING TO MOVE HIM BECAUSE
FOR WHAT THE PACERS ARE
MALCOLM BROGDON HAS BEEN IN
MY MIND THERE MVP. I THINK HE
MAY NOT BE WORTH THE CONTRACT
THAT HE HAS BUT IF THE
PACERS MU HIM THEN THAT
CHANGES THE DYNAMIC OF THEIR
TEAM GOING FORWARD IN A IN A
BIG WAY, I THINK MALCOLM IS
IT IS A VERY UNDERRATED POINT
GUARD IN THIS LEAGUE AS MUCH
AS MAGIC MIGHT SUGGEST THAT
LONZO BALL IS RIC RIC BUCHER
JOIN US FOX SPORTS NBA
ANALYST
ALSO, YOU KNOW ALONSO IS
LEADING ITS BEST YEAR IN
SCORING THREE POINTERS IN
FIELD GOAL PERCENTAGE. SO, I
HE'S GRADUALLY IMPROVING
EVERY TIME HE STEPPED UP FOR
A GUY THAT DOESN'T FOLLOW THE
NBA AS CLOSELY AS YOU DO OR
THE EXPERTS WE CONTINUE TO
SEE AND HEAR ABOUT IF IF
LEBRON AND AD ARE HEALTHY THE
LAKERS AND THE NETS ARE ON A
COLLISION COURSE, BUT WITH
THIS INJURY TO LEBRON AND THE
ABSENCE OF A
THE MOVING FORWARD ARE THEY
AND LET'S SAY ADD A PIECE
WHERE THEY CAN HELP THEM WIN.
THE PELICANS BEAT HIM LAST
NIGHT. ARE WE? YEAH, YOU KNOW,
WHAT'S THE FIGHT IS IS LONG
AS THEY GET IN AS AN EIGHT
SEED, YOU KNOW, THAT IS ALL
THAT MATTERS OF THE HOUSTON
ROCKETS FROM THE FROM THE MID
90S AS LONG AS THEY GET IN
AND THEY'RE GOING TO WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP BE A GOOD. WHERE
WE AT WITH THAT? YEAH. LOOK.
IT'S A FAIR QUESTION MEAN
FIRST OF ALL, WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT AD YOU KNOW WHERE AD AND
LEBRON ARE GOING TO BE WHEN
THEY GET BACK. I'VE BEEN
UNDER UNDERWHELMED BY THE
THE IMPACT OF THE PLAYERS
THAT THE LAKERS ADDED LAST
SUMMER MARC GASOL WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A PLAY MAKING
BIG THAT WAS GOING TO
OUTPERFORM DWIGHT HOWARD THAT
HAS NOT HAPPENED WES MATTHEWS
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE AN UPGRADE
FROM DANNY GREEN THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED MONTREZL HARRELL WAS
BE YOU KNOW THAT ENERGIZER
OFF THE BENCH THAT HE WAS FOR
THE CLIPPERS IN THE REGULAR
SEASON LAST YEAR THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED. HE HASN'T PLAYED TO
THE SAME LEVEL THAT IS
TRIGGER IS REALLY THE ONLY
EDITION THAT HAS DEFINITELY
BEEN A PLUS AND SO
I DON'T YOU KNOW WHERE THEY
ARE CAP WISE WHAT THEY HAVE TO
TO TRADE. I CAN'T SEE THEM
ADDING A SIGNIFICANT PIECE AND
THEIR BEST ASSET IS THE FACT
THAT THEY DO HAVE A CORE IN
COUP.
CHOOSE AN AED AND KENTAVIOUS
CALDWELL-POPE AND LEBRON
OBVIOUSLY A CREW THAT HAS
ALEX CARUSO HAS HIS WON A
CHAMPIONSHIP KNOWS WHAT IT
TAKES TO WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP
HAS THE CONFIDENCE THAT
WINNING A CHAMPIONSHIP BREEDS.
AND SO TO ME IT'S YOU KNOW,
DON'T MAINTAIN AS MUCH
CONTINUITY AS YOU CAN FROM
LAST YEAR. HOPE YOU CAN BE
HEALTHY AT THE RIGHT TIME.
THE SCARIEST PART IS
II MEAN I CAN SEE THEM
SINKING ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
THE YOU KNOW, THE SEVENTH
EIGHTH NINTH SPOT AND IF
THAT'S THE CASE THEN IT'S
SUDDENLY THE NCAA TOURNAMENT
FOR THAT. IT'S ONE GAME, YOU
KNOW, IF THEY IF THEY GET TO
THE EIGHTH SPOT OR THE
SEVENTH SPOT WHEN THE WHEN
THE PLAYOFFS START. OKAY,
THEN, YOU KNOW, THERE'S NOT A
REAL HOME COURT ADVANTAGE
WITHOUT FANS AND THEY'VE SEEN
EVERYTHING AND DONE
EVERYTHING. SO I THINK THEIR
CHANCES ARE JUST AS GOOD.
GOOD ASSUMING THEY'RE HEALTHY,
BUT YOU KNOW HOW MANY UPSETS
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE NCAA
TOURNAMENT ON ONE GIVEN NIGHT
IF YOU DON'T HAVE IT YOU'RE
SUDDENLY OUT AND THAT'S THE
PROSPECT THAT THE LAKERS
COULD SUDDENLY FACES, YOU
KNOW, THEY FACE A HUNGRY
DALLAS MAVERICKS TEAM OR
PORTLAND TRAIL BLAZERS OR WHO,
YOU KNOW NAME GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS. IT GETS INTO A GAME
WHERE IT'S POSSESSION BY
POSSESSION AT THE END AND
ONE MISSED SHOT ON THEIR PART
AND ONE MATE SHOT BY THE
OPPOSITION AND SUDDENLY
THEY'RE NOT IN THE PLAYOFFS.
THAT IS THE SCARIEST PART OF
WHERE THEY ARE IS THAT I
DON'T THINK THEY CAN HOLD A
SEED WHERE THEY ARE
GUARANTEED TO BE IN THE
PLAYOFFS. THEY VERY WELL MAY
BE IN A PLAY IN GAME AND
THAT'S A ONE GAME, YOU KNOW
DECIDES IT ALL THAT WOULD BE
WOW, THAT'S LAKER FANS.
YOU'RE OUT THERE. KYLE. KUZMA
IS THE HERO YOU NEED I
GUESSED RIGHT NOW. WHAT ABOUT
LET'S JUST TALK A COUPLE OF
OTHER NAMES BEFORE WE GET YOU
OUT OF HERE. WE'RE SPEAKING
WITH RIC BUCHER FOX SPORTS
NBA ANALYST ANDRE DRUMMOND
THE BUYOUT MARKET THERE AND
AARON GORDON, YOU KNOW, AARON
GORDON SEEMS TO BE A GUY THAT
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT IS A
GREAT PLAYER, BUT SEEMINGLY
KIND OF DENSE BEEN IN THE
BACKGROUND. SO ANDRE
DRUMMOND AND AARON GORDON
THERE.
YEAH, YOU KNOW THE DIFFICULTY
WITH THOSE TWO GUYS IS THAT
THEY FOR THE MOST PART HAVE
BEEN MAIN COGS WITH THEIR
TEAMS AND WHOEVER THEY WOULD
GO TO IF THEY'RE GOING TO GO
TO A MEANINGFUL TEAM. THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE A MAIN COCK
GUY. THEY'RE GOING TO BE A
GUY WHO POTENTIALLY COMES OFF
THE BENCH AND HAS TO BE A
ROLE PLAYER AND THAT IS SUCH
A DIFFERENT ROLE. IT'S ONE
THING WHEN YOU'RE THE MAIN
PLAYER AND YOU GET ALL THE
TOUCHES YOU GET ALL THE
MINUTES YOUR EFFICIENCY.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE WORRY IF
YOU START OUT 145 146 LIKE
I'M GONNA PLAY ANOTHER 30
MINUTES. I'M GOING TO GET
ANOTHER 15 SHOTS. I'M I CAN
FIND MY WAY BACK INTO THIS
GAME FOR WHERE THEY ARE.
THEY ARE NOW AND THE
POTENTIAL OF WHO THEY WOULD
JOIN THEY'RE NOW COMING IN
AND THEY GOT TO GIVE YOU, YOU
KNOW FOR EXPLOSIVE MINUTES
AND IT AND REALLY HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE GAME. ARE THEY
CAPABLE OF DOING THAT BOTH
JUST PHYSICALLY SKILL WISE
BUT MENTALLY ARE THEY WILLING
IT'S
LIKE AARON GORDON HAS BEEN
HAS WANTED OUT OF ORLANDO
SINCE THE END OF LAST SEASON.
IF NOT LAST SUMMER. I WAS
HEARING THAT HE WAS LOOKING
TO GO ELSEWHERE AND AND YET
THE MARKET, YOU KNOW ISN'T
THERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
PROVED THEMSELVES TO AT THIS
POINT TO BE REALLY GOOD
PLAYERS TO BE QUASI STARS
ON MEDIOCRE TEAMS, AND THE
WEIGHT OF THAT LANDS ON IF
THIS IS MY BEST PLAYER AND
WE'RE ONLY A MEDIOCRE TEAM
THAT MAYBE HE'S A MEDIOCRE
STAR AND THE QUESTION IS
GOING TO BE CAN THEY ACCEPT
BEING A ROLE PLAYER? CAN THEY
ACCEPT BEING A COMPLEMENTARY
PLAYER ON A GREAT TEAM AND
THEN YOU CAN THEY ACCEPT IT
MENTALLY AND THEN ARE THEY
CAPABLE OF PULLING IT OFF
PHYSICALLY AND THAT'S WHERE
THAT'S WHERE THEY ARE. AND
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVEN'T SEEN I
MEAN ANDRE DRUMMOND'S BEEN ON
THE MARKET SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR, YOU
KNOW, NOBODY'S JUMPING TOO.
TO GET ANDRE DRUMMOND BECAUSE
YOU KNOW, NOBODY'S LOOKING TO
REBUILD AROUND DRUM AND THEY
SEEM TEAMS THAT ARE BUILT
AROUND HIM AND YOU KNOW, THEY
DIDN'T GET VERY FAR SO AND I
JUST ON THE BUYOUT MARKET
LIKE I THINK MAYBE BLAKE
GRIFFIN IF HE'S HEALTHY CAN
DO SOME THINGS FOR THE
BROOKLYN NETS BUT LAMARCUS
ALDRIDGE ANDRE, DRUMMOND,
GORDON AYE THEY'RE THEY'RE
INTERESTING NAMES, BUT I
DON'T REALLY SEE THEM MOVING
THE NEEDLE I WOULD THINK THAT
ALONZO BALL OR A KYLE LOWRY
OR A MALCOLM BROGDON WOULD
HAVE FAR MORE OF AN IMPACT
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY GO.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE TALKING TO
RICK BUKER. YOU CAN CHECK HIM
OUT ON THE BALL PODCAST WITH
RIC BUCHER FOX SPORTS NBA
ANALYST BEFORE I GET YOU OUT
HERE. JUST QUICK ANSWER TO
THIS. I DON'T NEED AS OPPOSED
TO THE LONG ONES. I GAVE YOU
KNOW, I LOVE THAT. I LOVE
THAT. WE'RE IT'S A SIMPLE
QUESTION IS THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS.
RUN OVER
YES, THERE WE GO. I LIKE IT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I TOLD
EVERYBODY THERE TODAY. I AM
NOT AN NBA ANALYST OR A
EXPERT AND I TOLD EVERYBODY
GUYS THE WINDOWS CLOSING THE
WINDOW HAS CLOSED. YEAH. ALL
RIGHT. OH, NO THE WIND. YEAH,
THE WINDOW IS CLOSED. IT'S I
MEAN YOU LOOK AT THE AGE YOU
LOOK AT THE TREAD ON THE TIRES
AND YOU LOOK AT WHAT MADE
THEM SPECIAL AND UNIQUE AND
NONE OF THOSE THINGS ARE
WELL RICK, THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME RIC BUCHER
FOX SPORTS NBA ANALYST CHECK
THEM OUT ON THE BALL PODCAST
WITH RIC BUCHER. THANKS FOR
TAKING SOME TIME TODAY RICK.
MY PLEASURE.